I'm Sonic a little ball of super energy
in an extremely handsome package on my
planet people were always after my
powers so I came to yours as a visitor
from another planet Sonic the Hedgehog
sets out to live his best life on earth
while keeping his special speedy powers
secret when his presence is revealed
however he must emerge from hiding and
protect his power and the citizens of
Earth from a cruel villain but who
exactly is Sonic where does he come from
and why must he protect the planet
here's everything you need to know
before you go
introduced in 1991 for the Sega Genesis
game system Sonic the Hedgehog followed
the lovable blue hedgehog as he sought
to defeat a villainous scientist named
dr. Robotnik the game was well received
by critics and the public which inspired
many sequels and quickly became one of
the most popular game franchises in
history so have we ever seen Sonic the
Hedgehog on the big screen before yes
but it's only been in cameo appearances
until now
Sonic the Hedgehog appeared notably in
wreck-it Ralph making public service
announcements to remind other videogame
characters about the need for safety
especially when stepping outside their
own games he's a social creature and
enjoys visiting with people and is a
good friend of fix-it Felix jr. Sonic
returns in the sequel Ralph breaks the
Internet to explain the connections
between Wi-Fi and the Internet to the
overwhelmed Ralph as well as share in a
book club meeting Sonic also appears
more briefly as a character avatar in
Steven Spielberg's ready player one the
all-new Sonic the Hedgehog features the
first big screen starring role for the
beloved hero the film tells the story of
the world's speediest Hedgehog as he
embraces his new home on earth in this
live action adventure comedy sci Nick
and his new best friend Tom played by
James Marsden team up to defend the
planet from the evil genius dr. Robotnik
played by Jim Carrey and his plans for
world domination this kind of character
is like I had to find that evil genius
the combination of absolute intelligence
and and total worthlessness in his own
mind you know that combination is deadly
the family-friendly film also stars tika
Sumpter and Ben Schwartz as the voice of
Sonic
so they've been incredible voiceover
actors that have done this voice there's
a Roger Craig there's Jaleel there's
Ryan there's Jason there's a long list
of incredibly and people who've done
Robotnik man there's some great Robotnik
voices out there but the way that I did
it was I played the video games one more
time and then I read the script into my
head the way that the script played was
like it's like this young kid there's so
much energy who's never been allowed out
of this cave finally gets out as K gets
to do whatever he does and he's so
excited so I kind of just played it like
a little kid that's finally so
had to do whatever he wanted to do and
that just happens to look like that's
when you're watching the movie you feel
the warmth in connection between Tom and
this character because it feels like a
real little boy you know what I mean
that's kind of where I was becoming and
Ben Schwartz even took some inspiration
from a previous Jim Carrey performance
so there's a line that he does were in
Dumb and Dumber where he's like he's
talking about this thing this thing then
he goes our pets we got no food got no
jobs our pets Hector followed up and I
did that for this I go I got a fish on
my head
I'm wet I'm cold there's a fish on my
head so now you know and now you can go
see Sonic the Hedgehog
[Music]